it took 11 rounds of ivf for amber to
conceive her son
when she and her husband tried to give
him a sibling kovitch shut all
treatments down putting her dreams of
expanding her family in peril
for me waiting eight months i was
already 37 and when you're you know when
you're 37 eight months is a long time in
fertility and now we're at a year and a
half down the line and i'm a year and a
half older more than that now
and we're still not anywhere um so i
think it's that it's the time pressure
that you'd have in your late 30s that
really kind of added
to the to the stress and the worry
a survey by the charity fertility
network uk found that kovid delayed ivf
treatment for more than half of the
respondents
and that lost time experts say can make
a difference between being able to have
a baby or not
it does cause a lot of stress
particularly for women who are older and
who have reduced egg reserve
the time is of the essence and that puts
additional stress on them because they
are concerned about their egg reserve
going down
and their chances of having a baby with
their own eggs
when treatment resumed for lauren and
nick coveted protocols meant they
couldn't see a nurse to show them how to
prepare medication and were given a
booklet with instructions instead
it was just so hard to try and just read
that without going having a nurse to go
through and then go right yeah this is
how you do it
did you have any guidance as to how to
do things properly
we couldn't ask any questions at all
really there were no one to show us no
there's nobody to show us nobody to tell
us what to do nobody said reassure us
even
that we were doing the right thing
lauren got pregnant after three attempts
but for many couples delays meant
diminishing chances of having a much
wanted child
milana veselinovich sky news